[Music]
what are you doing
uh they were just asking about the
family who's about to tell us about her
super awesome guests oh mirabelle didn't
get one
you didn't get a gift
um
delivery
i gave you the special since you're the
only madrigal kid with no gift i call it
the nut special special since uh you
have no gift
thanks
oh and antonio good luck last gift
ceremony was a bummer last one being
yours that did not work
if i was you i'll be really sad
well my little friend i am not because
the truth is gift or no gift i am just
as special as the rest of my family
all right guys where do i drop the wagon
maybe your gift is being in denial
[Music]
[Music]
and that's why coffee's for grownups
[Music]
if you're impressed imagine how i feel
[Music]
lift it higher
[Applause]
my baby's night has to be perfect and
it's not perfect and people are going to
be coming you're commanding the flowers
the flowers did someone say
flowers
or angels or angels please don't
thank you oh it's nothing
the little sisterly advice if you
weren't always trying too hard you
wouldn't be in the way actually isa this
is called helping and i'm not in the way
you are
what if you didn't understand what he
saw then you better figure it out
because it was coming for you
we don't talk about through no no no no
we don't talk about bruno
[Music]
[Music]
says
[Music]
louisa can you rear up the river will do
lisa the donkeys got out again
lisa
wait a second
you've got to tell me about the magic
what's going on what are you hiding
nothing just got a lot of chores so
maybe you should just go home lisa my
house is leaning to the top
dolores said your eye was twitching it
never twitches something's making you
nervous move you're gonna make me drop a
donkey
luisa we just
just tell me what it is there's nothing
to tell you're obviously worried about
something lisa if you know what's
hurting the magic and it gets worse
because you won't tell me what's wrong
nothing's wrong
wow uh sorry that uh that snuck out
there i'm the strong one i'm not nervous
i'm as tough as the crust of the earth
is
okay
i move mountains i move churches can i
glow cause i know what my worth is of
course i mean hey where are you going i
don't ask how hard the work is gotta
rough and destructed the surface
diamonds are platinum i find i'm a flat
num i take what i'm handed i break
what's demanding button
[Music]
i'm pretty sure i'm worthless
[Music]
till you just go
[Music]
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
la casita
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was given their own magical gifts
uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
con queso
casita what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
the fate of the family it's gonna come
down to you
i can't do this let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
[Music]
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
i'm stephanie beatriz the voice of
mirabelle let's go and i'm john
leguizamo the voice of bruno hello
in disney's encounter get ready to meet
the most gifted family around
the madrigals
first thing you need to know abuela is
in charge luisa is super strong
antonio can speak to animals
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you isabella
can grow flowers and bruno peppa can
control the weather dolores has super
hearing yeah but bruno's amazing gift i
almost forgot camilo's shape-shifting
well i can heal injury with food
you just healed my hand with the narepa
and finally there's mirabelle she's
still figuring herself out you didn't
get a gift
didn't get one maybe your gift is being
in denial yeah but what about bruno i
mean he's we don't talk about bruno we
don't talk about bruno so you're telling
me that bruno
we don't talk we don't talk about bruno
seriously i even wrote a whole song
about it
[Music]
okay okay geez but really quickly bruno
can you
talk about bruno
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
delivery
i gave you the special since you're the
only madrigal kid with no gift i call it
the nut special special since uh
you have no gift
uh thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gift or no gift i am just as special as
the rest of my family
who wants more pink all right guys where
do i drop the wagon maybe your gift is
being in denial
[Music]
let's go music can help tell stories in
an animated realm
in kanto working on original songs with
12 original characters it's really
really exciting
there's this family the madrigal family
and they've been blessed with these
magical gifts
[Music]
i told them to warm up your seat thank
you tonito
these characters are having emotional
breakthroughs and reunions all in song
the filmmakers put a great amount of
faith in me to be able to musicalize
this so i feel really great
[Music]
with every musical project i'm trying to
find the pulse of the characters the
song i wrote for isabella is called what
else can i do and for that i was really
inspired by the 90s rock and espanol
movement
and was about finding those colombian
rhythms that are so unique
[Music]
colombia has a lot of rich musical
traditions within itself that are unique
to colombia but also there's an
incredible amount of variety colombia
music is special because we do it with
our heart you know we do it with love
it's a beautiful story in every song
[Music]
i wanted to just write the most joyous
song possible a love letter to colombia
itself
obviously carlos vives is a worldwide
music figure i was in love with his
music already that song is so inspired
by his writings and so to have him sing
on that is like a dream
[Music]
a star in colombia and he has an
incredible voice
my manager called me one day and she's
like hey so disney's doing a new movie
about colombia and i was like yes yes
yes just say yes
[Music]
this was such a joy to work on this
it's one thing to write the song but
then to see the thrilling visuals that
was an incredible experience
[Music]
you